turkey has resumed airstrikes against
Kurdish fighters in Northern Syria on
Sunday Jets bombed areas controlled by
the ypg a Kurdish group linked to the
pkk which turkia considers a terror
organization the defense Ministry says a
ground offensive will be launched as
soon as possible Ankara blames the ypg
for recent attacks in Istanbul and
gaziantep accusations the groups the
group denies
everybody was expecting a ground
operation last night and uh there are so
many Turkish media Outlets I positioned
themselves in Gaza and Japan Killers but
of course these kinds of offensive uh
offenses are also based on negotiations
but what everybody expects on the ground
inside Syria and among the people that
we have spoken to so far this is
imminent and an operation must be coming
soon according to the expectations
turkey is preparing for an election that
is scheduled for uh June 2000
2023
of course the military operation is not
the main target main objective of an
election campaign but definitely it
would impact the consequences it would
it would have consequences as the
Turkish people not only the ethnic Turks
or the others but even ethnic curse they
are again they are mostly against the
Workers Party pkk is a tax on the
civilians so after Istanbul bombing
there is a public opinion that that has
shown solidarity against these kinds of
uh Terror attacks definitely this would
bring some votes for the Turkish
president who is allied with the
Nationalist party as well but as I said
this is not the main objective of the
operation the main objective of the
operation is to complete a health job
that was left half in 2019 when trukia
launched an operation against the
Kurdish Fighter Group ypg